Sally sold seashells by the seashore,...
...but her seashells didn't sell so well.
Shucks.
So Sally set up a seashell store on Squarespace,...
...and soon her seashells started selling.
Suddenly, Sally was a seaside sensation,...
...so much so, she also sold swanky seashell accessories,...
...shiny seashell sequence skirts and sarongs,...
...seashell serenity sessions starting sharply at sunrise,...
...exceptionally savory seaside snacks.
Seriously?
Even seashell excursions of the seashore.
To sum it up, Sally's seashells were so successful,...
...she sailed into the setting sun as a seashell celebrity.
Shucks.
Everything to shell anything, Squarespace.